[Musique]
y'a plus personne
tu vas passer les meilleures vacances de
ta vie ça va aller tu verras tu vas te
faire plein de copains
bienvenue au camp aventure du bout du
monde alex c'est le mollet de la colo
logan je t'aime trésor
zen zen je sais pas si c'est une bonne
idée de s'éloigner autant on devrait
peut-être faire demi tour
suivez moi c'est quoi ce bordel
jamais vu cet oncle à de ma vie ces
indépendances des eaux n'est pas en
juillet gabriel attend donc les adultes
s'aperçoivent qu'ils nous ont laissés
mots c'est énorme ce truc j'arrête de
parler tu prends la ferme la ferme et 1
et sa terrasse
ce que je trouve ma mère
faut qu'on aille en ville
restez où vous êtes c'est la guerre vous
n'êtes pas en sécurité
[Musique]
partez où va pas vous laisser là ans est
clair c'est à vous de jouer
c'est clair pouvoir d'arrêter les
agnelles on devrait trouver jpl un
centre de la nasa
c'est à plus de 100 kilomètres d'ici
vous voulez vous taper sans borne pour
aller en ville
une mustang macoine de 1973 je connais
que les automatique
just
c'est la loi de la jungle
on s'est débrouillé tout seul ou n'a pas
fait tout ce chemin pour baisser les
bras maintenant oui je suis votre maire
au nom s'est passé assez je suis le
maître faut vraiment qu'on trouve une
nana
j'aimerais porter un toast à la
bouteille et de 1969 j'ai quand même pas
boire du vieux vin pour ma première fois
c'est mort
[Musique]